okay so this is a big energy and there's
three things you need to get
okay the first one is stay in the back
and the second one is learn to lock his
body by controlling the lower arm and
then the third one is
let the energy
of his movement
do this wrong not not you do this
okay
so
get
[Music]
get in the back
control his arm
so
pressure pressure velocity centrifugal
energy
then it doesn't just go into his
shoulder
but goes into his body
[Music]
you see how much slack there is
there should not be slack
and his forward progress that's the
threat
this is different
those three things
are in the key
[Music]
so
so the first thing to help you is to
understand the 10 con as i have
described it here which is to get in the
back i wouldn't describe how many
degrees of rotation that is or
you know
where it is in relation to the the four
cardinal directions
it is where it is and you have to move
there so you can't have your
you know what this is my normal tank
time
do you understand so you're here you get
you do i always do 180 degrees you see
and then uh when you come back around
well now you're
in the front
you have to just stay in the back how do
you stay in the back stay in the back
okay so if you pay attention and you ask
yourself is that a 180 degree tank on
i'm going to say for this uk and the
amount of energy that he's given me i
can't do the 180 it's it's bigger than
that okay so if you just pay attention
to that part they're coming around
so if you want to ask yourself so the
180 i should be facing that way at the
end of the tank but if you if you ask
yourself oh where where are my faces
okay got it
so you can't have a pre-planned
this is by tencon no that's not that's
not that's not what tencon means that's
how i was introduced to you but that's
not what tancon means
point number two
from the arm you must be in the body
do you get it
i i always have to be in his body it
can't be in his arm
it has to be in his body
can't be here
can't be i pull him down and then it
pulls his shoulder and then it makes his
head move it's wherever i'm touching
it has to be in his body okay
so if you pay attention
it's already in his body it's already in
his body you see it's already in his
body
it's already in his body
i'm not over here
in his arm
it's already
in his body
in his body in his body in his body
still in his body around
so this is in his body which is why you
don't need the
other arm of kodage
in his body
in his body in his body
do you think
what we have same reason here hey learn
how to do this body with homologous
transitioning cross lateral hand
hold on
transition
into the other hand it's training okay
meaning
did not view his body
until you get this torque is not the
technique
lastly
uh
think about
what you would want to do marshally with
the back breakfall he's falling to the
rear
what's my target
back of the head okay
do not
try to turn him over
do not let him turn himself over
okay
so as i come around
i am not i don't want him to turn
towards me do you see
and i don't want him
to escape out the bottom
with a forward roll
okay
so if you pay attention
turn towards me
you see
and then i keep my movement
turn towards me
he's not allowed to turn towards me
because i have the body lock point two
every single time before i even get to
the throat okay
and so
try to get it where his center is going
forward
there's the back of the head
you see this is no big
arm throw which is really just an arm
pull
okay i just locked his body from the
beginning and then i use this spiraling
cross pattern he hits it
and he runs into the kazushian okay try
for that